alors c'est un jour c'est le petit marc
comme ça il arrive il va voir son papa
il lui dit papa papa papa c'est quoi qui
entre les jambes de maman il est bassam
en shérif ça c'est la porte du paradis
mon coeur dia et papa c'est quoi toi
entre tes jambes et bah ça c'est la clé
qui ouvre les portes du paradis et ben
papa tu ferais bien de changer de
serrure parce que le voisin il est là il
faut faire mieux perso je ne trouve pas
mieux que le mec il y aura quelques le
panier tu va retenter dois tu veux ont
tenté tout de suite où tu entends des
rongeurs il faut il faut faire mieux
c'est cuit à la merde alors vas-y
j'ai nagé les bosses cacher une vanne
avec un génie qui peut concurrencer à
dire une autre veine de génie donc c'est
un haram qui se dit tranquille c'est un
arabe qui arrive qui arrive au quartier
à il a acheté ma dernière maserati a
tiré deux fois la mode et nous croissons
potes sont patents renault 5
son pote arnaud sangle descend de la
voiture du rattachement maserati est oui
dit je t'échange maroon 5 contre ta
maserati et en plus je rajoute cette
lampe le tutorial gilbert tu vas pas
mettre vraiment inquiet comme ça je m'en
fous de talent que moi j'ai une maserati
j'avoue net à renault 5
lui dit non mais regarde à satan il
frotte sur la langue comme ça il ya un
génie qui sort et il dit au génie génie
fait nous du thé le génie sans une
théière comme c'est leur fait deux
verres de thé y boit il est choqué tous
idiots qui ne changent soudainement
maserati fait benoît taraude aux 5 et la
lampe
il lui donna rhône 5 et la lampe il
arrive devant chez lui les contacts
klaxons klaxons et klaxons sa femme et
soeurs elle voit son mari avec une
renault 5 ha comprend pas dit mais
qu'est ce qui se passe et toiles où la
voiture est tous les dix ans montrent
inquiètes montrent inquiets dont sa
femme et mon dans l'aventuré tout lui
frotte la lampe le génie sort il dit au
génie génie donne un gros gros sacs de
bijoux à ma femme
le génie au regard dit diane en désolé
moi je sais faire que du thé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
patrice ipad
michel base il ya deux tunisiens et à la
tunisie et à paris et il envoie des
lettres tout le temps son cousin il fait
chaud il j'ai bien géré à paris roulant
à paris qui tombe à savoir les femmes en
icône gay comme les quotidiens vient
paris tu peux pas savoir la vie qu'on a
c'est une merveille vient à paris notez
enfin il en a marre y prend son costume
et prend son couffin et mais les dates
les noix il prend ses pompes au piment
tabac et il arrive et son cousin il a
fait bouffer saint-michel ya plein de
vie boulevard saint michel
il avait pu passer si je venais clé je
venais y est écrit dans la rue je venais
culte et la personne son cousin et de
trouvailles à personne il va voir at il
en effet j'y comprends pas où il il m'a
dit ronnie qu'ici à paris qu'est ce que
ça veut dire y'a rien n'y a pas de fille
à rien moi je vous dis que c'est une
bonne question et le typhus écoutez
monsieur l'afld savez c'est noël alors
tout le monde et à la neige donc si vous
voulez comme vous dites
giblet copuler wells noah copé il faut
il faut aller à la montagne à megève et
je n'ai qu'à me gêne à megève vous avez
une chance peut-être en avril ultra les
trains et motos l'otage vini qu'il a
mouché et dans les rues de menin l'image
fait venir au bout d'une heure deux
heures la nuit tombe il commence à avoir
froid il fait bon je veux ni que mes
chiffres alors ils entrent dans les
hôtels le premier hôtel it et bonjour
moi lâche unique et medavoy la petite
chambre
il fait à monsieur c'est complet elle
élabore mont d'arbois c'est le plus
grand hôtel de megève peut-être vous
avez il arrive au mont d'arbois
grandhotel c'est bonjour voila
voilà voilà voilà j'ai un peu fatigué
jeunes pousses loi même si je n'y pense
pas trop j'ai froid je vous donc mieux
lotis vif écoutez je suis désolé j'ai
remis mes nous l'envoie de chambre je me
complais à ce moment là parce madame la
comtesse de ribambelle qu'il fait au
concierge
mais fernand que se passe-t-il il dit
que ce jeune homme là est très présent
oui oui oui c'est eux les embêter ou
l'âge et flo a même un plaquage il est
comme ça je donne dans le placard avec
le ballet je nique le ballet fait
écouter n'en ont pas de chance je ne
sais pas quoi est fait écouter et c'est
purement humanitaire qui est pas doute
monter dans ma suite à des coups de
suite
j'arrive dans la suite avec la femme et
fm et vous allez lui mettre un petit
quand ça va être très bien
sewell d'accorder deux camps étant
d'accord mais sur les cas elle lui donne
une couverture ça comme tu es libre en
couverture la couverture s'affiche pas
l'habitude c'est la neige elle d'écouter
c'est purement humanitaire venez dans
mon livre est vraiment ne ne pensez pas
à la mauvaise chose a vraiment moi moi
je ne pense pas j'ai pas le cerveau
moelle et il est fatigué il est rien je
dormais
les faits écoutez d'ailleurs nous allons
faire une chose très simple faisant
remettre les skis entre nous et comme ça
il pourra rien se passer
bien sûr les milices qui larmoient rouge
et ce qu'ils y voient là tu vois moi je
dors même ex'im plus que cynique et se
met au litige à ce moment là dans sa
tête ça grouille quand même fait [ __ ]
la comtesse de ribambelle
je suis juste à côté dans le monde
arbois voilà je suis venu pour le nikkei
gimmick pas elle est la côte est juste à
côté
je m'en fous je glisse une une patte
église une patineuse qui tue à elle dit
rien en avant je glisse la jambe quand
rien je lis les deuxièmes pattes les
deuxième jambe elle dit rien jouant sur
elle put rien avant j'étais rien j'y
suis incognito
j'ai commencé mes clinique gêner la
comtesse de ribambelle fait aaa c'est
exquis ces textes c'est exquis de
bishop's et tout ce qui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors pour l'instant je pense que c'est
michel d'être au fait est-ce que tu toi
tu es un autre gîte peut-être que tu
peux peut-être c'est une femme qui
achètent une armoire ikea la montagne
quatre heures compliquées toi on croit
que c'est simple m et 4 heures à montre
l'armoire et tout quand tout est fini il
ya le bus qui passent devant chez elle
puis si une route en pavés ça tremble un
peu
et tout l'armoire s'écroule à feu non
c'est pas possible elle recommence tout
ce coup ci avait que trois heures que
trois heures elle mais tu vois tout est
bien fait pour elle et où elle a terminé
le bus passe sa trempe sur les pavés
l'armoire s'écroule
là elle appelle les cas et écoutez je
suis avocate fier bien fait le truc est
tout maintenant si vous m'en voyez pas
quelqu'un dans l'heure qui suit je
voudrais d'injustice et votre marque
vous allez voir la pub que je vais lui
faire ils flippent tellement chez ikea
il envoie un mec fait oui je connais le
modèle qu'est ce qui s'est passé deux
fois et s'est écroulé ok je m'en occupe
le mec qui montre la revoir les
meilleurs c'est son boulot démontre
l'armoire et 1,2 ce qui passe par moi
s'écroule et c'est bizarre quand même
parce que moi je vais je connais mon
métier il n'y a pas de raison je refais
il refait en trois quarts d'heure et bat
son record et montrent la revoir le bus
passe l'armoire s'écroule
il est alors peut-être ça viendrait
peut-être de l'intérieur si je me
mettais à l'intérieur qui est davis
intérieur extérieur si je me mettais à
l'intérieur je vais te tiens défaut de
fabrication davis ça me permettrait de
localiser le problème je m'attends à
l'intérieur fermez fermez le truc qu'on
va attendre que un but soit on va bien
voir le mec se met dans l'armoire et là
il ya le mari de la femme qui rentre et
fisher est assez noir c'est génial tiens
je vais aller traîner je met mon raison
il ouvre l'armoire et là y voit un mec
accroupi dans l'armoire garde le mec le
mec fait bonjour vous n'allez pas me
croire mais j'attends le bus
[Applaudissements]
la famille al vraiment vous sur et
carole alors moi c'était un homme qui
marche dans la rue et qui va croiser là
il aperçoit une sublime femme avec une
silhouette absolument magnifique et au
moment où il la regarde un peu il ya des
visages de la tête aux pieds il la
regarde un peu un peu lourdement et au
moment où ils vont se croiser elle le
toise parce qu'elle a bien vu son manège
et elle lui dit monsieur vous n'aurez
pas mon coeur et il lui répond mais je
ne visais pas si yo madame c'est
l'élégance
on a on a ça y est on a l'élégance on à
chantal ladesou on à voile a toujours
cédé blagues sur l'algérie veut nous
faire imitation on a le taulier on a 20
cents voilà exactement vous c'est les
devinettes et baffie c'est le sale bah
on va sentir je pense que c'est quand
même dangereux
je pense que faire que des lunettes mais
avec l'accent québécois d'accord bah tu
feras tu te feras que dans une autre
émission les moins chers
[Applaudissements]
dans l'élégance dans les histoires et
les gardes comme ça il y aurait une
quête que j'aime bien c'est ça qui est
une histoire vraie c'est winston
churchill et oscar wilde qui se
détestaient et oscar wilde envoie à
winston churchill un mot en disant je
vous invite à la première de ma nouvelle
pièce je vous envoie de place venez avec
un ami si vous en reste un et oui
surtout chili en voilà la réponse je dis
moi je viendrai la deuxième
représentation si on a une restaurant
mafieux dans la petite italie à new york
et donc c'est jean ah ok tient le
restaurant et tony travail pour lui et
donc gino et les détourner étonné ton
est bien là bien là mon christian bale
dans les toilettes
es tu te demandes s'il te plaît c'est
passé familial
oui ah non mais moi je fais je la leur à
l'isie alice n'accroche pas d'accord on
prend je fais bassett comme témoin au
procès très sympathique où je vois mon
nom me lévy il dit tourner s'il te plaît
va te branler aux toilettes
jeudi et hier mais pas trop non non non
non tu mexique et le patron c'est une
photo blanc les autres thoniers
l'exécutent évidemment il va aux
toilettes y revient au bout de cinq
minutes 5 6 minutes qui revient est un
peu gêné comme ça et jean louis dit
alors fait on est ok ils le laissent
tranquille dix minutes tournent et
retournent au toit dre blanc toi tu es
nouveau je viens d'y aller à 10 minutes
on ne sait pas trop si c'est moi il
s'énerve et tout donc l'utile et
l'atonie va et au bout de deux minutes 6
heures il dit je ne peux plus je veux
plus me dis ok maintenant tu es branlée
créé dans la voiture et trois femmes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces messieurs vous à tva proverbe apple